décidément la ville de lyon est
précurseur en matière de circulation
après avoir lancé le système de vélos en
location bien avant paris et ses vélib
voici autolib sur le même principe des
voitures en libre service pour une heure
ou pour une journée de quoi résoudre
peut-être en partie les problèmes
d'embouteillages et de stationnement
jean-christophe bacteria et federico
nicotra la multiplication des transports
alternatifs à la voiture finit par
porter ses fruits
les déplacements automobiles viennent de
passer sous la barre des 50% ici à lyon
l'autolib pourrait améliorer le score
contrairement au vélib qui fait la
promotion du vélo
l'auto en self service devrait aboutir
un usage raisonné de la voiture ce
restaurateur du centre ville a franchi
le pas sans nostalgie pour cette vieille
de chevaux bon avec mon épouse yann mais
un plan on avait trois bagnols
aujourd'hui ma pub voiture on est en
centre ville et je peux vraiment passé
entre le vélo vélib
et puis ce système là je publie une
voiture l'autolib est né du mariage à
trois d'une association de partage de
voitures d'une entreprise de parking et
de la communauté urbaine de lyon
cette société d'économie mixte propose
sur 22 parking 70 voitures à 700 abonnés
une voiture pour 10 personnes vous avez
cette fraction de la population
qui a même plus du tout envie d'avoir un
véhicule un soir qui considère que la
voiture est un objet d'utilisation
commode pour certains déplacements et à
ce moment là
cet outil peut très bien être partagé en
commande de la micro citadine à
l'utilitaire vous pouvez 24 heures sur
disposer d'une voiture les formalités
sont fait une fois pour toutes
vous payez à l'heure et au kilomètre une
vingtaine d'euros pour la demi-journée
contrairement aux vélos la voiture doit
être restitué à son emplacement de
départ est la clé remise dans l'armoire
à corte c'est l'objectif du service de
réduire le volume de déplacements
motorisés
donc si on accorde de pouvoir faire un
trajet unique simplement un allez on va
favoriser des petits déplacements qui
n'ont pas forcément lieu d'être
d'après la mairie à partir de 3000
abonnés l'impact sur la ville sera
perceptible circuler à lyon pourrait
même redevenir à plaisir sachez